so i am um optimistically hoping
that there are going to be travel
possibilities
coming up over the next uh six to nine
months i do
in theory have a wedding in europe i'm
supposed to go to in september
so i sent in my passport for renewal on
january 5th
this year and i sent it by regular
postal mail
and it wasn't even received by the
passport processing center for nearly
three weeks until the last week of
january
and the postal service has never been
more kneecapped than it is right now
and a big part of the reason is donald
trump's choice for postmaster general
lewis de joy
who has been wreaking havoc at the post
office for the better part of
a year longer at this point in time
louis de joy
insisted at a hearing yesterday that
we'd better get damn used to him
because he plans to stay in his position
a long time take a look
you're a political appointee a holdover
no one knows how much longer you're born
that's that's incorrect i'm not a
political appointee i was selected by a
bipartisan board of governors and i
would really appreciate if you would get
that straight
well how much longer are you planning to
stay
a long time get used to me
well joe biden has a clear plan to
removing
louis de joy which would be really great
for the country
and anyone who either sends or receives
mail which is most people
for everyone wondering why louis de joy
is still on the job and why joe biden
hasn't simply removed him and replaced
him with someone else
it's because the postal service board of
governors
chooses the postmaster general it's not
as simple as joe biden can just
replace louis de joy so what joe biden
and congress
are going to need to do is to fix the
postal board of governors before they
can have them removed the only other way
i can think of
uh removing the postmaster general would
be for joe biden to make it a cabinet
level position
so he can just pick a new postmaster
general that seems like it would be
relatively difficult to do
so what joe biden is planning to do is
he is going to nominate
three additional members to the u.s
postal service board of governors
if joe biden's nominees are confirmed by
the senate
this would then give democrats and
democratic appointees the
majority of that postal service board of
governors it's almost like he is
packing the court except it's packing
the postal service board of governors
having that majority
the postal service could then vote to
remove louis de joy
from the position of postmaster general
the three nominees
uh for joe biden are reportedly going to
be ron strowman who's a former deputy
postmaster general
amber mcreynolds the ceo of vote at home
which promotes voting by mail
and anton hajjar who's the former
general counsel
for the american postal workers union so
the plan is very clear
nominate these three folks they get
approved by the majority democratic
senate
you get a majority on the postal board
of governors and then you get rid of
louis de joy now whether it will happen
that smoothly remains to be seen but
this is an emergency as a reminder the
postal service
has been a target of the american right
wing for a long time
remember that the way this fits in is
that the right wants the government
doing nothing
and as an independent agency under the
executive branch of the government the
right
really wants to get rid of the postal
service one thing they've done
is required that the postal service
pre-fund
pensions of workers decades in advance
which
on paper makes the financial situation
of the postal service look much worse
than it actually is
no for-profit industry has to pre-fund
pensions that far in advance it was a
calculated measure
by the right to argue that the postal
service is financially insolvent
another way to hurt the post office is
to make it work
so poorly that people stop using it
which then makes it
even less viable and lewis the joy has
done many things to make the postal
service work less efficiently
including eliminating overtime pay for
mail carriers so that undelivered mail
at the end of the
normal work day instead of getting
delivered simply goes back to the post
office and gets delayed
sometimes for one day sometimes for many
many days and as we've seen
under louis de joy on time mail delivery
has declined from 96
to 80 some parts of the country like
detroit
even lower 74 on time mail delivery
and this is sadly a key part
of the republican playbook rail against
a government department or a government
entity or a government
an organization overseen by the
government then
put they get themselves put in charge of
running it they make it run even worse
and then they say look we told you guys
this is terrible well yeah you're making
it terrible
and then somehow they'll blame democrats
and then when democrats come in
and put together a plan to fix what
republicans
ruined republicans say who can afford
that that's really expensive
this thing is functioning so terribly we
would need so much money to fix it we
can't afford that well why is it running
so terribly
it's running so terribly because you
destroyed it so it's a very common
republican playbook and uh it is
one that unfortunately has worked well
in many areas so
we see the path three new postal
board of governors members postal
service board of governor members
get them confirmed by the democratically
controlled senate
vote to remove louis de joy put someone
in that position
who actually wants to improve the
functioning of the postal service
rather than worsen it which is exactly
what louis de joy wanted to do
and it's exactly what he has done one of
our sponsors is vincero
watches giving you 15 off a high quality
wrist watch
is the perfect way to elevate your style
own at least one watch that makes you
feel great when you put it on you can
often see me wearing
my ventura watch on the show mine is the
gunmetal
vessel model i'm a big fan of the
metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six thousand
five star reviews and they stand behind
every watch they make with a one-year
return policy and
five-year warranty they'll give you 15
off everything in their store and free
shipping at davidpakman.com
watch use the coupon code pacman